wow
it's very exciting
[Music]
what's going to happen
hello everyone and welcome to tonight's
lecture it's been a while
um Ben has informed me it's been five
years three months six days 17 hours and
12 minutes but who's counting who's
counting oh boy that I loved doing my
Grandmaster in residencies and the
various lectures my favorites were
children's lectures oh I just love
teasing the kids
but it's been a long time I've been
doing a lot of broadcasts obviously for
the club and it's really nice to see the
Grand Master in Residence program going
so well with so many great players
coming and sharing their
gangs and their thoughts and somehow I
don't know exactly how I did it but I
finagled my way in and I got a chance to
do a lecture so thank you all thank you
all for coming it's really really nice
and thank you uh for those of you in the
chat who are sending me all kinds of
smiling faces
they're smiling face
but uh yeah there okay so great I I get
to do a lecture and what could I lecture
on so I'm sitting there thinking what
should I lecture about and I am not
joking almost at the moment I got the
gig to do this lecture
it was incredible there was a tournament
going on in Norway it was the first
round of the Norway stabbinger chess
tournament
and it was Fabiano versus Magnus
and Fabiano and Magnus well as you know
going back to their world championship
match in 2018 they've been throwing the
patties at each other for many many
years and and many of their clashes it's
been number one versus number two
and I don't care what your sport is I
mean whether it's Sprint racing boxing
chess snooker when number one place
number two you gotta stop and watch the
match and
Bobby won the game his first victory in
classical chess over Magnus in eight
years I was like whoa this is perfect I
know what I'm going to lecture on I got
this I mean I'm here in St Louis it's uh
fabby's Hometown how could I not do a
special lecture on their on their game
and Fabi opened up E4 and as you know in
their world championship match uh games
it was really this vashnikov variation
that Fabi had trouble breaking
and in fact in their world championship
match game
in the world match world championship
match I want to say uh none of the
classical games not a single one ended
in a victory all of the classical games
were drawn and uh Bobby had a very hard
time getting any advantage against
Magnus in the conventional and so he he
threw in a rasa limo here there Bishop
B5
to mix it up but again Fabi could not
break magnus's defenses and it's not but
he couldn't break magnus's defenses it's
just that he didn't even get advantages
and that's really really annoying you
know you're white you want to be you
know something going on
so uh I was very very curious to see
what Bobby had prepared against this
vashnikov and Jan nepo
in his world championship match in Dubai
he had a hard time getting anything
in a very conventional rui Lopez
Magnus
defended incredibly well against nepo as
black and
so when when Fabi opened up E4 I was
expecting the classical E5 as well as
this vashnikov by Magnus and for me I
mean we know Magnus can play anything
and I remember a game he had with
I think it was Mickey Adams from an
Olympiad he even believed this I don't
know if you remember the game but it was
like
let's say Magnus got his just desserts
in that game and he lost with the black
thesis uh Mickey won but really the
problem when you're playing against
Magnus when you're facing Magnus is he
can play anything he can play anything
and even though he did choose to play
the French defense and he has played the
French defense it was a little bit
surprising for me I thought that we were
for sure going to see a a clash of this
vashnikov or even a conventional
classical
by the way I also want to say that this
lecture is really so informal and it's
meant to draw you in and to ask
questions so if you ever at any moment
have a question and say this that or the
other thing just raise your hand and
I'll call upon you and I'll and I'll ask
you now the crazy thing is virtually
anywhere you go
in professional chess today anywhere you
go whatever your opening is whether it
be a perk defense a
scotch
my gosh a Russian defense wherever you
go
the opening theory is advancing
almost with avalanche-like speeds I mean
today more and more and more games are
being captured
by captured I mean in databases so I'm
even seeing in databases uh title
Tuesday Blitz Games and believe me those
title Tuesday uh tournaments are really
really strong so maybe we should be
paying attention to the Blitz Games but
if you start including those Blitz Games
then the millions of databases games
just keep growing exponentially and
you'll see that
the opening theory is is really really
advancing so almost one of the questions
that I'll ask you ah you think it's just
a one-way ticket not so fast
is
when did Theory stop
whoa in other words the two players
played down and accepted pathway that
opening Theory modern Theory describes
that you should do this and this and
this and this so where did they deviate
where did they stop uh modern Theory so
Knight C3 okay against the French
defense
I must say I was always very happy as
black when they played the clothes today
uh the advance pardon me the advanced
French when they played the move E5 I
was always happy as black when they did
that and in fact on numerous occasions I
often played like this as black
don't laugh
but I I had very very specific ideas
about the French defense and I always
liked it when they played the advance
and today the advanced variation is
considered maybe the most dangerous or
formidable
Knight D2
um the tarash or Knight C3 the winner
were now for Fabi while he plays also
light Magnus just practically everything
I think he has a favorite towards the
winner word Knight C3
here I like to tell a short story
that against the Terrace
there was the 1974 world
finals candidates match so in 1974
there was the match Victor korchnoy
versus Anatoly karpov
the winner of that match and it was a
24-game match that finished three to two
in favor of Anatoly karpov the winner of
the match would play against Bobby
Fischer
in the 1975 world championship match a
match that did not take place
because Bobby didn't play
in that match
Anatoly karpov played Knight D2
and Victor was rather reluctant to go
into the steinits and he was looking for
an alternative
and his second Yasha Murray said
you should play Bishop E7
a nice little waiting move it's a
waiting move and it says to White go
ahead and make a move
and
in those days it was a rather dangerous
to help Victor korchnoy because Anatoly
karpov was the favorite son and Victor
course no it was a little bit un favored
so Roman jinji Hajj vili
helped Victor korchnoy during the match
but did so by telephone
so Roman called Victor and said Victor
I've got a great great idea on the third
move you should move your Bishop
and yes said Victor Yasha Murray told me
I should play Bishop E7 no said Roman
Jin Josh Philly you should play Bishop
D7
so the idea of them and I actually
played Bishop E7 very very successfully
now the idea of the move Bishop E7 is to
give White
the move okay so if you were white and
you were facing this position for the
first time
what move would you play and anybody
who's got
ideas let me know would you play Knight
F3 how many in the audience would play
Knight F3
okay very good how many in the audience
would play Queen G4
not so many takers
how many in the audience would play the
move C3 C3 kind of keeping the pawn
protected how many like C3 okay
so you see the move Bishop E7 has caused
you to stop and think what what should
you do how many like the movie E5
five E5 okay E5 I see yeah there's some
some some takers with the move E5 so
it's sort of like you've played an
advanced
French you played the move E5
blacks played strange little move Bishop
E7 and you've convinced yourself that
the best answer to Bishop E7 is Knight
D2
well it's very interesting how you get
those moments like this where Knight D2
Bishop E7
you present your opponent with the move
okay
so for those of you who like to move C3
and there is absolutely nothing wrong
with C3 one of the things you always
like to do is shop and compare right
so if against Knight D2 you wanted to
play the Akiba Rubenstein variation
takes takes Knight takes Knight D7 one
of the things you would not do
is in this position so you're not
interested in C3
you're really not interested in C3 at
all what you're really interested in
doing
is
setting up a situation where you're
castling long now when you cast along
the move c2c3 is not only not required
it's actually loosening the position up
so when you start in this moment after
Bishop E7
with the move C3 you're actually
inviting black to transpose into a
Rubenstein variation where the move C3
is wrong
for those of you who like the move
Knight F3 one of the reasons you play
Knight D2 is that after Knight F6 E5
Knight D7 you get to play F4 and you
play for the big Center you get the
clamp you clamp down on the center with
F4 and
oops now you put your knight in the way
of F3 you're almost obliged to play
variations like this one
where it's not everybody's cup of tea
but you often end up sacrificing
upon on D4 now again that's very very
standard stuff and you've got lots and
lots of lots of games where that pawn
sacrifice is common
so when you are facing Knight D2 there's
a lot of flexibility on black side when
you plays Knight C3 your your flexible
moments go way down it's sort of like
this Knight on C3
um it put some pressure for first of all
there's no Bishop D7 anymore that would
just hang the D5 Pawn
and against Knight C3 really theory has
said the pathway is very narrow
you either Play Bishop B4
the winner were variation E5 how many of
you recently saw
the game between the swanathon and non
and Magnus Carlson that was played in
Dubai
that was a magnificent game and maybe uh
this game convinced Magnus that he
should play the winner
and not the steinits line so for the
better part of
150 years Knight F6 has been a very
conventional move for the French and
after E5 Knight D7
F2 F4 has been
thousands and thousands of games
with four quick question for my audience
if you had white and the opponent played
94.
Knight E4 here and you're surprised by
this move right because like wow
everybody's been playing Knight D7 for
so long and now suddenly your opponent
plays Knight E4
what's what move would you guys play
would you take the Knight
how many of you would take the night
okay how many of you would move the
night away like 92 in order to try to
try to win the Night
Trap the night with F3 and H4
interesting for those of you who would
take the night night takes Pawn takes
how would you follow up what what move
would you play the move Bishop E3 just
that looks like a pretty
normal conventional move right would you
play Bishop E3
or would you play another move here
which one Queen E2 well one thing that
the the Knight has done that trade no
worries uh is that uh
why you you would love to play a move
for example like Queen G4 here and pick
up the pawn queen takes there are a lot
of variations where you have these
tricky ideas they simply do not work
here because of Bishop B4 check
but
it was really funny because now today
they have computers and the computers
will immediately tell you 94 is a bad
move
but at the time before the computers I
played Knight E4 in a couple of games
and I did really good
especially when my opponents would play
moves like C3 and or Bishop E3 I would
play a very quick C5 and I'd get a very
easy game
somebody and I believe his name was
Brian Mclaren
played the move Bishop C4 against me
and that put the kibosh
on this line the problem is this Pawn on
e4 is actually
weak not in the immediate term but in
the long term
and the move Bishop C4 is designed to
stop me from playing C5 because of D5
and I was in trouble as black I end up
playing a move like B6 but after Knight
E2 Bishop B7 castles I simply did not
like my game at all as black white was
very quick to play Knight to G3 Rook to
E1 and I ended up crying
I was losing upon
okay back to the game F4 C5 Knight F3
Knight C6 Bishop E3 I'm looking in my
database and I'm seeing tens of
thousands of games and we're not even
close to the Tavia position Queen uh
Queen B6 has been by far
the most conventional move for uh
decades I want to say and queen D2 and a
lot a lot of modern games
will feature this capture on B2
and the variations are very very long A7
A6 is the second most popular move and
certainly uh Fabi
is incredibly incredibly well prepared
just about anything and I'm sure for
Fabi he did most of his work
on Queen B6 because he could expect that
most of his opponents would play the
move Queen B6
after the move A7 A6 one of the whole
Concepts
of the French defense is that as black
you're a counter-attacker okay you're
basically saying as black you're making
the following argument
come forward step forward put your Pawn
on E5 grab
The Lion's Share of the center and I'm
going to counter-attack you in the
center with the move C5 as well as the
move F6 so I'm going to attack your
center from the sides with those two
moves
now White's whole strategy is hey I've
got this big imposing Center and I'm
just going to sit on you I'm just going
to hold on
take all the squares in the center of
the board and you're going to suffocate
your pieces will have no good squares
and
from the middle game to the end game
you're just going to suffer a space
disadvantage so the two
sides make their intentions very very
clear
one of the things that you'll notice
about White's position I'll ask the
audience
what is White's worst
peace what is White's worst piece do you
guys think the bishop on F1 is bad
yes no no no yes no no you think the
bishop on E3 is bad yes no no no yes how
about the night on F3 everybody likes
that right what do you guys think of the
night on C3
exactly exactly no Bravo for the night
I'll see there the night on C3 is
actually in the way the move A7 A6 by
the way has really taken away one of the
very few squares that the Knight can
jump to freely and Knight B5 and Knight
E4
in an Ideal World white would just like
to play the move c2c3 reinforces Center
and that is why Knight E2 is one of the
most conventional moves for white along
with very very standard stuff Queen D2
now I played this position as black in
my practice and against Queen D2 I took
and played Bishop C5 I believe against
Nick defermian in one of the U.S
championship games that we competed at
that game was a draw
and this move Knight E2 I think is more
suitable
to the position from White's point of
view from White's point of view he knows
that the counter attack is coming on the
D4 square and on the E5 Pawn after F6 so
92 is sort of like preparation I'm going
to play the move c2c3 completely making
my Center impregnable
and
then you've got a problem as black what
are you going to do with your pieces
think of that about the the suffering
Bishop on C8 as well as the suffering
Knight on D7 what are you gonna do so 92
really
throws Down The Gauntlet to Black and
say well you you better do something
because as soon as I play C3 you're in
trouble
Queen B6
Queen C1 in this case the threat of
capturing the pawn on B2 was very real
all of this again Bishop E7 C3 all of
this is absolutely conventional opening
chess Theory so like when you turn on
your engines and you play through the
game every one of the moves thus far
with the exception of maybe A6 will be
the top choice of the engine
after castles
well white has a bit of a problem
White's problem is that well
is night is better placed on E2 than on
C3 but this bishop on F1 is kind of
suffering is that like coach you got to
get me in the game like what are you
doing you got to do something help me
coach so G2 G3 uh
also very very conventional the idea
here is Again The Bishop's diagonal is
blocked
the bishop is is looking to play to G2
defending the Knight prepping castles as
well as Bishop H3 again all standard
Theory F7 F6 Bishop G2 at this moment
I'll pause and I'll say how many of you
like the move Bishop H3
Bishop H3
just a little just a few hands me I
loved it I I was like why don't you play
Bishop H3 why don't you play Bishop H3
that looks like a a really decent move
uh to my eyes you're threatening to pick
off a pesky with a check
and Life's good right
and it's really funny uh
Bishop H3 by the way is conventional it
has been played in numerous games and in
many of the games
black plays the move F5
which is kind of funny like you you just
played F6 to open up the game and then
you played F5 to close the game down
and it's sort of like well why did you
do that well it turns out the bishop is
not that great on H3 and G2 is actually
a better diagonal for reasons that are
oftentimes associated with C3 C4
the other problem with the bishop on H3
is that black knight on D7 is well I
think the scientific work word is crap
it's like what what is the Knight doing
on D7 the queen
on B6 is in the way and it's really
conventional in these positions that
black plays the move Queen B5
tagging the Knight if you will in order
to play the move Knight B6 and again the
bishop is actually misplaced on H3 okay
uh
I like the move Bishop H3 that would
have been maybe my choice and the most
conventional move is Bishop G2
C takes D4 interestingly enough in this
position Queen B5 is also a major
alternative
and has been played as well
C takes D4 C takes D4 Queen A5 check
another funny move Queen B5
invites the Knight to come back to the
square C3 and the queen drops in on the
D3 Square so at this whole Queen D5
Queen D3 maneuver I thought was kind of
funny Queen A5 check is uh
magnus's move then the crazy part is uh
well it's coming up so far we all agree
that this is
Theory right and Knight C3 is a normal
move how many of you like to move Bishop
D2
they should be two blocking blocking the
check
with the tempo
yeah it's pretty good right well that's
that's the main move
Bishop D2 and then the game goes Queen
to D5 Queen to me Queen to B5 and again
black is looking to play Knight B6
Bishop D7 Rook C8 he's looking to drop
his Queen in on D3 but
according to
my very weak database uh Knight C3 a
move the computer likes a lot is new
whoa I mean that's looks like a pretty
obvious move to me and uh well it it
gets the novelty according to my
databases which again aren't that great
okay Knight C3
Knight B6 and now we come to a major
moment a major moment for Fabi
okay
why Why didn't
Magnus capture on E5 why don't you
capture on E5
why didn't he get yes
yeah so F takes E5 F takes E5 yeah so F
takes E5 F takes E5 this looks like a
pretty straightforward thing and then
Knight B6 so from Black's point of view
black has opened up the f file it's
prepared to play Bishop D7 he's prepared
to play Knight C4 you played the move F6
why didn't he follow through with uh
capturing well it's sort of like the
players
wanted to
not give their opponent an option
so in this position
Magnus could capture on E5
or played the move he played in the game
which was Knight B6 but if he captures
immediately on E5 he gives Fabi an
option that he doesn't have in the game
the option that he gives Fabi is the
move Bishop G5 what do I mean f e f e
Knight B6 Castle
now it's actually here if you don't
immediately play the move Knight C4 much
like the game you've got to be a little
bit scared that white might play B3 and
stop the knight from coming to C4
but let's say the Knight does come to C4
Knight C4 now
it would be nice from Black's point of
view if there was a Pawn on F4 so that
this bishop would have to retreat to F2
if there was a Pawn on F4 I I
would prevent me from playing the move
Bishop G5
so imagine we continue Bishop takes G5
Knight takes G5
okay
well wait a minute
the opening of the f file
who benefited from that well if you look
at the position you can actually see
it's pretty clear that white is the one
who's benefiting if you play Knight
takes D4 Rook takes f8 check King takes
f8 besides the fact I can all already
grab Knight takes H7 check I also have
Queen F4 check
and there are some very very complicated
uh variations that now continue Knight
F5 G4 Queen B6 check it's really
annoying when you get a position like
this and your engine goes triple zeros
[Laughter]
how can you say triple zeros I mean
without ah it's really really really bad
but also Knight takes H7 check is
another one of those variations
that ends up also for some reason being
a triple zero
here the computer likes playing Queen G4
check before picking up the Knight and
giving white just a tad of an advantage
so it's sort of like I was really vexed
in this moment why Magnus didn't take on
E5 and play Knight B6 and I really
wanted to find out and I went down a
rabbit hole with my chess engine and
there went my afternoon
and I still don't understand
I can't forcefully say that the move ft
F6 takes E5 uh was better or worse
Magnus played Knight B6 and now here
it's sort of like again the players are
like bluffing a little bit with each
other because
uh
Fabi did not want a castle Knight C4 and
being denied the opportunity for Bishop
G5 here he thinks well after Bishop
um
Bishop to F2 takes on E5 takes on E5
Bishop D7
fabi's not happy he's looking around and
he's saying this bishop is a little
passive this Bishop's a little passive
what exactly is going on here what am I
doing
so in this position
recognizing that he doesn't want to have
these passive Bishops Fabi captured on
F6 first a move I really like I like
this move a lot because essentially if
you capture with the pawn well your king
is going to be a little bit loose always
always always it's like white has this
move F5 that hangs over the position
white is ready to play castles and
anytime you take on F5 a move light
Knight H4 is going to give white a very
very promising attack
so it takes you're forced to take with
the bishop and the move b2b3 it was very
important that
in this position you don't play the move
B3 why don't you play the move B3 why
what's wrong with B3
yes yes
precisely that's exactly right after you
remove Bishop B4
yikes uh
my knight is really in this very awkward
pin and I'm virtually forced to play
Bishop to D2
in these types of positions French
defense players love these sacrifices
just as Sicilian players if you're black
and a Sicilian and open Sicilian you
love to play Rook take C3
when you're on the black side of a
French defense you love to make the
exchange sacrifice Rook takes F3 and
this is a very conventional opportunity
here you don't even think about it you
just do it
you sacrifice The Exchange on F3 you
grab a pawn
and
you just hope it works
usually it does let me assure you
usually it does
but this is exactly what Fabi wanted to
avoid so he captured on F6 first he
distracted the bishop away and only now
played the move b2b3
stopping the night from coming to C4
okay
but as we say you know each move has its
pros and cons I love the move B3 and I
think a lot of players would happily
keep that night at Bay and probably for
the same reasons they would like to play
A3 and keep the other night
stuck on the C6 Square
but each move has its pros and cons and
in this case the pawn on B2 was
defending the Knight found on V3 is not
defending the Knight so Bishop D7
castles Rook C8 comes right away and
bingo Bongo we've got to be careful
that something we don't have an accident
on the open uh sifa Queen D2 so for the
moment Knight takes D4 doesn't work why
doesn't Knight take Steve why does
Knight takes D4 not work
what's wrong with my takes D4 everybody
plenty
the ship takes D4 Bishop takes D4
Knight takes Queen ticks
haha that won my Pawn Julian
and the Knight is hanging yes exactly
so no tactics at the moment the problem
is the night on B6
is hanging
so
Bishop to E7
well we've seen this issue before as
soon as the bishop drops in on B4 we've
got an issue we've got a real real
problem
I would have thought that as white
how many of you would play the move A3
A2 A3 here
so the idea is just to stop Bishop B4
right
but then why not what if we had this
really really annoying opponent
and he took the pawn on A3
and he said well
prove proved me wrong proved upon
sacrifice well it turns out
I mean even though you're putting
yourself in what what looks like a
terrible pin
there's no way to exploit it my my
computer engine if it says Bishop takes
A3 is really fine for black
and it's just like oops
so I'm sure at the board
such thoughts went through fabby's mind
and he said I'm Magnus is going to take
the pawn if I put it out there he's
going to grab it he played 92.
92. and
it's rather reluctant that white is
trading Queens because white really he's
he's thinking to himself how am I going
to stir up trouble on the king side
and keeping Queens is usually something
that white wants in these French middle
game positions Queen takes D2 Bishop
takes D2 Rook to C7 and
it's kind of strange if something goes
wrong like Rook C7 looks like a very
decent move to my eyes but if something
is going wrong it starts to go wrong for
Magnus at this moment
right here things start to go wrong
so we're going to criticize magnus's
move Rook C7 and say
you're you may be the number one player
in the world
but I'm gonna educate you
so that's what we want to say so how do
we go about doing that educating the
number one player in the world
well
the position
is not full of sharp tactics there's not
like we've got to analyze checks and
captures
not that I could see rather what I like
to do is I like to go around the board
and look at all the pieces and I talk to
my pieces and I say how you doing are
you happy are you happy are you happy
are you happy so if I'm in black shoes I
go who's happy
and blacks Rooks tell me
I'm great I'm doing fine coach my Rook
on C8 says I'm on the open file that I'm
I'm happy
this Rook says well I'm on the half open
file I'm happy so the Rooks are happy
the night on C6 is pretty happy this
bishop which has a pretty good view of
all the proceedings it's kind of happy
maybe the bishop on D7 is a little bit
unhappy kind of it's it's kind of like
wedged in there you know like a wedgie
it's a little unhappy
and you know you know it might start
thinking to yourself as black you know
what I'd really like to do is I kind of
like to sit on these squares A3 and B4
so something like Bishop A3 Knight B4
Rook C2
yeah yeah I can I can feel it I I'm
getting my mojo going here I can see
that Bishop A3 is a very attractive
looking move
but there's one guy in the position
that's crying
what piece of blacks is unhappy what
piece of black is the most unhappy
yeah the night I'll be coach what are
you doing to me yeah look at this this
night on B6 is not capturing its own
person can't go to C4 can't go to A4 so
the Knight on B6 and this is really what
I do is I literally I go down and I talk
to my guys and I say who you know who is
not performing well and the night on B6
is that's me
Knight on B6 is I'm not performing well
so there's two things that you could do
to improve the night's performance one
is to get rid to
to open uh the D7 Square
vacate the D7 Square play a move like
Bishop E8 idea Bishop G6 and Knight D7
or play the move Knight A8
not everybody's cup of tea but
if you've got the time to continue your
development with Knight C7 Knight B5
pressuring the pawn Knight D6
closed positions allow you these
maneuvering opportunities open positions
you don't have time to move a night
three four five times to get the Knight
to an ideal Square you might just be
blown off the board by the the very
nature of open position here I would
have said that conventional moves like
Bishop E8 and or Knight A8 better suit
the needs of the position after the move
Rook C7 Rook to C1 Magnus followed up
with the very natural looking Rook C8
again from magnus's point of view he's
ready to play Bishop A3 on a good day
night B5
and he'll say to the night on B6 ah
stay quiet rest of us are fighting yeah
you you'll do fine I'll I'll let you
into the game uh later but it's exactly
at this moment that Fabi has a very very
nice tactic
a very nice tactic
what did Fabby play
throw it out there if you know the
answer
here it comes
are you ready
here it comes Okay so we've talked about
magnus's position and what Magna should
have done and why the Knight on B6 was
kind of like not ideal from White's
point of view
there's a lot of things about his
position that need Improvement
first of all the Knight on E2 is no
great shakes right like you would love
to put the Knight on D4 so you start to
think to yourself I should play a move
like 95 force a trade of knights and
maybe recapture with the D4 Pawn so I
could put my knight on D4 my knight on
E2 needs a better life
my Bishop on G2 you know okay it's
protecting my king but it's kind of
boring like the night the bishop on
Jesus 2 is playing a rather limited role
Fabi finds a very very nice move F4 F5
that does an enormous amount of good for
White's position the first thing it does
is it opens up the bishop and look at
here that Rook on C7
it's actually trapped
it doesn't have a square so Bishop F4
could snag an exchange
second of all when you play the move F5
you want to capture on E6 so that your
knight you could capture on E6 the
Knight can go to F4 and really
attacking the bishop on E6 attacking the
pawn on D5 and the bishop on G2 is
really really uh
happy
by the way I mean our street performers
we've got some St Louis Blues going on
here so that comes with the lecture it
comes with a lecture but if you want to
tip the guy
you're very very welcome there's a whole
band out there
and they're just right on the corner of
the club as well so I really like the
move F5 and I think it's here where the
tables really started turning for Magnus
because
um it's no longer easy for him to play
yes he could play a quiet little move
like Bishop to D6 but after takes takes
takes it's actually white who's getting
a very nice initiative
uh going
um the Rooks on the C file
are actually well
they're not that great anymore
all right
Magnus
drops in Bishop A3
Rook to E1
and Bishop to B4
so here we're kind of
uh
leave it over to you guys and
again imagine yourself
in fobby's shoes
this is now your game okay
and
you see that your pieces The Rook on E1
The Rook on F1
the bishop on G2 the Knight on E2 ready
to spring to F4 Square all your pieces
are ready to come to life
but you have to play the precise series
of moves
to prove your advantage
so
you're white call out your moves go
ahead
if you were white what would you do
okay I'll do it another way how many of
you would like to take on E6
I like that how many of you would like
to take on B4
how many of you would like to do both
like at once well
oftentimes
when you have these moments where you
have a choice
between two desirable captures
make the capture
that limits your opponent's options
so if you want to play Bishop takes B4
and you want to take on E6 take the
bishop on B4 first because if you take
the pawn on E6 yeah he could take back
and yeah you kind of expect that he
would but you also give your opponent a
different a chance to make a different
move he could take on on D2 and in this
case after you take on Ethan he's got a
check
and now you have to calculate something
a little bit differently
so when you have the choice of making a
capture make the capture
that forces your opponent's hand in this
case Bishop takes B4 Knight takes B4
he has to take takes takes and now
back over to yourselves
okay
actually this one is kind of too easy
right how many of you want to play
Knight F4
those of you who don't want to play
Knight F4 have to leave the room
because Knight F4 is a move we live for
I mean this is this is like the Petals
of a flower you know opening up the
night on E2
is
a passive Square
on the F4 Square holy smokes look at
this the Knight reaches into Black's
position tax the bishop on E6
The Rook is on This Magnificent open
file Knight F4 is super duper
okay Bishop F5 your turn
let's see what are our candidate moves
how many of you would like to play Rook
to E5
repeat five nice how many of you would
like to play Knight to E5
Knight to E5 nice okay how many of you
would like to play Knight to H4
oh Julian you like Knight H4
or did yeah okay uh
laughs
oh okay
so uh
here
my thinking and the way I approach chess
is there's no question what I'm doing
I'm playing the move 95. okay I'm
playing the move 95.
and I'm doing it for very very very
specific uh reasons
first of all
Knight's love to be centralized I mean
you play chess long enough you really
really respect a centralized Knight
secondly Knights actually get better
when they're defended
like what it's a very very strange
property it's sort of like night's love
to be in literally a nest where they are
protected the night on E5 is protected
by the pawn on D4 but once you put the
Knight on E5
beautiful things start to happen first
of all
did you hear the cheering of the bishop
on G2 right that's really really nice
secondly did you notice that you might
be threatening A3 and Knight takes D5
and then finally and this is not an
inconsiderable point when you put the
Knight on E5
see this bishop on F5 doesn't have a lot
of squares to go to the night on E5 does
what for White's position what's another
benefit of this night on E5
squares for division yes it does it does
it limits the squares for the bishop
defends the D3 squared but also defends
the G4 Square which means that the
bishop can't go to G4 not that the
bishop actually wanted to go to G4 but
it does allow
G3 G4
after the move Knight E5 and let's see
what would have happened for example on
Knight H4
so after Knight H4 let's say I would
play Bishop E4
and more or less Julian you want to take
it yeah yeah take take okay so take take
Knight E6 and let's drop
down
Knight F5 and for what it's worth this
Knight on DC on B6 that had been out of
the game at least is not crying
you know uh we could take a pawn
we could take a pawn
um
and I'm just not sure it might be one of
the it might be a situation where white
is actually doing really well but it
also might be a situation where after
Rook takes A2 we're allowing a lot of
counter play that maybe maybe we didn't
want to allow
Knight H4 is a move that you want to
play when you calculate something that's
very very forcing that really works out
very well in your favor I'm not a
hundred percent sure that the move
Knight H4 this is one of those
variations that
that it it appears to me to be very
forcing yeah but it could also be one of
those things that maybe
um if the if the engines go triple zeros
on me
I get upset
I really love the move Knight E5 I just
like I mean for for me that just is like
this enormous link of a chain 95 G7 G6
okay
now
here we go here we go
we're playing against the number one
player in the world
Magnus Carlson he's just played the move
G7 G6 which defends the bishop because
there was you know ideas of a discovered
attack
with Knight takes D5 and Rook takes F5
and issues issues Galore
what what did fappy play what did Fabby
play
how many of you like the move a2a3
e2a3
how many of you like the move G3 G4
G3 G4 very nice move
and here again it's one of those things
that you're given a choice of very
attractive moves so the first thing is
you really really want to play Knight
takes T5 like that would just be you
know dream right but the night on before
the night on B6 both defend the pawn so
the urge to play a2a3 get rid of the
night kick that night out of the way is
a very very strong one
but then you analyze you go a2a3 Knight
C2 Knight takes D5
we go well Knight takes E1
uh
uh you start to panic right Rook takes
E1 allows Rook C1 Knight takes B6 uh
Knight takes G2
Knight takes
93 and
you start
to wonder if you've done it right
like uh
not so sure so a2a3 might lead you
astray might lead you astray the other
thing about a2a3
oh excuse me
a2a3 is after Knight C2 Knight takes D5
imagine Knight takes D5 Bishop takes D5
King G7 yay
this is great
right this is really great we've done
exactly what we wanted when we played
the move A3 we wanted to win that pawn
on D5
and now it's sort of like well maybe
we're not so excited anymore about our
position because the night on C2 is
actually really
annoying who allowed the night on C2 to
be so annoying it's hitting the pawn on
D4 it's hitting the night pardon me the
Knight is hitting the Rook on E1 and
worst of all black might be able to play
Rook d8 in the very near future
indefinitely win his Pawn back in short
the move a2a3 leads us on the wrong
track
but we come back to the position and we
see the move G4 and we go ah where is
the bishop going
if we could entice
the bishop to the C2 Square
wow now the move a2a3 is really
attractive because the bishop is
occupying the C2 Square the Knight on B4
will have to go Knight takes D5 and
White's position plays itself so the
move G4 actually is the best
the most forcing and Fabi played it
Magnus played Bishop E4
here I'm not going to ask you guys
because this is a yes or Sarah one
lecture and yes sir Sarah won't say I
will tell you take the pawn
bishop takes Bond takes a2a3
and he took the pawn
uh exactly here funnily enough my engine
says that uh
Magnus played the mistake Rook well
mistake is strong
an inaccurate move is what the computer
says the engine actually suggests Knight
takes F4 and Knight D5 and considers
that white has a significant Advantage
after Rook F7 but not a winning
advantage
perversely from the way I think about
Chess
I'm absolutely convinced that when
Magnus went through this whole complex
complications after the move F5 he had
reached this position in his mind
and he played the move that I really
want to play as black which is Rook to
C3
this looks like a really great move
because after all you possess
the open C file
why not play the move Rook C3 and
captured these pawns and you know the
other Rook could come down
any nitrates
really seem to be okay for for
um
black in other words Knight takes D5
Knight takes D5 not a problem Rook takes
B3 is on Black's agenda but
now it gets hard now it gets tough
here is where Fabi found a really really
nice move and this is where I put you on
your toes
what move did Bobby play as white
um
Knight E6 okay that looks like a very
nice move
it definitely covers a lot of squares it
doesn't exactly
well you can't play Rook f8 so that's a
good thing
I must I'm going to ask
what is the follow-up tonight E6
I mean it looks like we're just gonna
capture the pawn and ask white to prove
the point
not sure
we'll try again
another suggestion yes
97th
that was the move that Favi played and
it is a really really powerful move and
I'm absolutely I have no doubts that
while Magnus probably it flickered in
his mind that Knight D7 was such a
possibility he underestimated the power
of the move Knight to D7
so what white is actually threatening if
it was white to move white would play
the move Knight takes D5 so for example
Rook takes B3 Knight takes Knight takes
and Rook to E5 this is what is the
threat that's what it's all about right
there
so you really have to do something and
it's not easy uh to make a suggestion if
you play Knight takes F4
then I've got Knight takes B6 that's a
Tempo against the rook and that's the
tempo also against the Knight
in the game Magnus has played Rook takes
B3
Knight takes D5 Knight takes D5 and I've
like the magician that spoils the trick
I've already showed you what uh what the
threat was and the threat of Rook E5
this is uh
this is uh the problem
um black has
no move
he has to move the Knight and after
Knight C3
what did
what did Fabi play
this one should be easy easy peasy
Rook C1
G5 G5 that's a nice move
how many of you like the move G5 it's
coming from the chat
not many takers
that's good that's good chat
how many of you like Knight F6 check
uh
Knight F6 check
is a killer move uh the computer thinks
that there is a stronger move in the
move D5 but essentially Knight F6 check
and Magnus resigns I mean it's a pretty
good move when your opponent resigns
right you know like I don't know but uh
that that that's really nice and the
whole point is Magnus did not want to
see uh moves like King G7
Brooke Chad King Rook uh King is going
to walk the plank and you're gonna get
mated uh
after H4 right
you have to play after Knight F6 check
King here and once again you don't want
to go
and walk the plank
after Rook E5
and from this point on there's a force
made
so from the position that Magnus
resigned in you have to actually play
King f8 and after Knight takes King G8
pardon me
and then after Knight F6 King f8 and
this is just not what the world's number
one had in mind so this is the first
game that Fabi has won in eight years in
classical chess against Magnus Carlson
so let's give an Applause to Fabiano
that's very very very very nice
and that for me uh it's always thrilling
when american plays against a world
champion or plays against the number one
player in the world I always you know I
cheered my colleagues uh whenever they
had that opportunity and winning and
winning in a very
convincing style I think Fabi can take
about at this moment I'd just like to
turn over the conversation the lecture
to yourselves is there any questions
about the game something that happened
earlier maybe you would have
well
yes
so
sure um
yes the Knight F6 move is dubious yes
yes
uh it it thinks that this move is second
best if you will and it really likes
pushing the pawn it really likes the
idea that you should play D5 D6 night
Shack and D7 it thinks the moment you
get your night on F6 you get your Pawn
to D7 that is Johnny ball game so it
really really likes D5 I really really
like Knight F6 check and funnily enough
once more after move by King
f8 I like grabbing the pawn the engine
also really really likes the move Diva
so I take the pawn man like the engine
thinks that black should should play in
this position King f8 so it's sort of
like great if you want to play
King G8 and King f8 and I get to take a
pawn for free give me the pawn with
three and then I'll think about I'll
find the move D5 don't get me wrong
that's that's a pretty uh convincing
looking move and there's nothing wrong
with pushing a pass Pawn especially a
centralized bass Pawn but that was that
was the answer that sometimes the engine
likes variation in this case D5
and the human instinct is to get ahead
get ahead
and I think behind you a gentleman in
the red yes yes I have the same question
the same question wow I got a two for
water
that's great just a second let me give
myself a kiss
uh any other questions
well in that case I want to thank you
all very much for coming it was a real
treat for me uh like Ben says it's been
quite some time that I've actually just
been able to give a lecture uh normally
uh doing the broadcast and the
broadcasts are coming up it's as you see
behind me uh we've got some tournaments
coming to St Louis but our very next
broadcast we have rehearsals tomorrow
the grand Chester
flares Anew and um yeah rehearsals
tomorrow Wednesday is round one in
Croatia in Zagreb the rapid and Blitz
will begin and by the way it will
feature as a wild card one of the wild
cards in the 10th player
um round Robins will be Magnus Carlson
Magnus as you know gave up his if you
will call it that his classical World
Chess Championship title and Magnus
really enjoys playing
Rapids and Blitz and it seems to me that
that's where he's really concentrating
himself and he enjoys that and he's
going to be a wild card so that will be
coming up grantchester
then following the grand Chester right
behind me I have my reunion
my I don't go to my high school reunions
I go to the U.S Senior championships
the U.S Senior championships I get to
see all of the chess Legends those
players I did battle with for so many
hmm
decades sounds pretentious but yes so
many decades and that's coming up but
also uh Legends and the future will have
the girls uh championships uh vote those
of you Atlas Lee a top top uh player
will not be the number one player in the
field in the girls competition do you
know who the number one player in the
girls competition is going to be
not Alice Lee
Carissa yeah Carissa yep is is attending
in Stanford
she declines
the U.S women's invitation she's the
number two player in the United States
for the ladies competition Carissa is
but because she's going to Stanford and
because the U.S Women's Championship is
played over uh days that she has to
attend schools she declined but she's
coming for the girls competition and
then of course there's the junior
competitions we don't say the boys we
say the Juniors because any of the
ladies could qualify and I believe for
example Carissa would have been
eligible or play in the Juniors if she
had wanted
so we'll have the seniors the legends of
the past and we'll we'll get a glimpses
of the future so a really good events
coming up and it all start with the
grand chess Tour on Wednesday
with that I want to say thank you all
very much and it's been my pleasure
really really really really really
really really great it's really great
and my thanks to Chad and of course our
our
computer
photographer Audio Man extraordinaire
Ben Simon everyone Ben Simon
uh don't be booing back there
thank you all have a good evening
bye-bye
it's 2023 and the grand chess tour is
back for its eighth trip around the
world inspired by former world champion
Gary Kasparov the grantchester hosts the
top players to compete for top prizes
eight of the world's best joint
tournament wild cards and travel to four
different countries to fight for a 1.4
million dollar prize fund the tour kicks
off in Bucharest Romania for the
Superbad chess classic then things speed
up as we move to Warsaw Poland and
Zagreb Croatia for the first two rapid
and Blitz events the tour then makes its
way to St Louis Missouri for the final
two events we're back in November for
the St Louis rapid and Blitz and the
illustrious sinkfield cup when points
are up for grabs the best players show
up who will be crowned the new Champion
find out when the grand chess tour
returns